well I got a couple of questions for you
guys I got a lot of stuff I mean you
guys are not only famous for your music
but you're legendary for all the Antics
I mean here we go I thought I've heard
about everything that you guys did
listen to this Nikki Nikki once tried to
have sex with Tommy Lee's mother what's
wrong with that she's Miss Grace yeah I
don't understand someone you got a guy
who's your drummer yeah
you want to keep the band together it's
in your financial interest it's your
future we weren't very smart back then
she's a MILF was she enough Tommy how
old were you at this time I was like
eight I don't know no really how old
were you at the time uh the band just
started what like 22 or 20 probably 22
Yeah right so you're a 22 year old guy
full of life you meet Tommy's mom and
she was like 23. now how old was Tommy's
mom at that point like 40 no no
early 30s early 30s younger than we are
now really yeah and she was totally hot
hot man
and where do you and like how did you
try to have sex with her uh I think I
was just yeah I want to hear this too
yeah I don't know I don't really
remember I just remember where did you
like like you met her at his house are
you guys we used to you used to like you
know have like parties and stuff at uh
at Tommy's house or at our apartment or
wherever and I think I was drunk one
night and was kind of oozle kind of you
know yeah
and like what is she walking around in a
thong or a bathing suit or no it's
nothing like that I mean and she and but
she's Tommy's mom don't you go like Mom
that's Tommy's mom maybe I should leave
her alone we were sort of into anything
back wow that was Tommy pissed no no he
didn't care he doesn't care he calls me
dad now
the story in the book was that Tommy's
dad found out about it and he said hey
man if you can get it you can have it
yeah wow that part's true yeah I think
that's why I mean everybody in the
band's a little bit crazy but a little
bit broken yeah but Tommy's Dad saying
if you can get her oh that's just a
confidence thing wow so did you get her
you didn't get her hell no no and Tommy
didn't care all right let's go through
some of these things Nikki was with Ozzy
Osbourne when he snorted the ants off
the ground which is legendary that's
true yeah we were all there we were all
there yeah why did Ozzy why did he snort
ants he was just out we'd been doing an
all-nighter and uh ran out of drugs and
he said he wanted to do do some you know
do some more and he took a straw and
just snorted up these ants do you think
he did it because he wanted to impress
you guys that he was kind of like no
Ozzy does not do things to impress you
he does things like that because he's
you know he's out of his brain do you
think that he was doing it to get high
I think Ozzy just doesn't care when he
gets in that state he just does anything
and he snorted up live ants yeah wow
that's after he remember he uh after he
looked after he peed or you peed and he
looked up the people yeah yeah off the
ground yeah off the ground the answer
nothing so he had to top there so so
that so that that it was like Animal
House right be touring with Aussie it
was like Animal House wow and you guys
actually matter of factly about this
stuff it's it was very normal then very
normal yeah yeah absolutely all right
that's why nothing really bothers us but
here's what I don't understand Nikki
once punched Vince
in an airport after Vince told him he
was quitting the band no no it wasn't
there was a hotel hotel in San Francisco
he punched you yeah he punched me too
yeah we were punching each other it's a
miracle you guys are back together
really good a lot of bad blood went down
I forgot about that I'm pissed again
that's when I took the jet back and you
guys uh still yeah gonna get on the
plane yeah I'm like nope see ya he took
the Jet and left us here's something
that upsets this is something I read
about you none of this upsets me except
for this one thing okay I'm ready you
once urinated on the leather jacket of
Cheap Trick guitars Rick Nielsen I think
Rick is a
a genius he is Oh I thought maybe you
did it as an act that you didn't like
him no no way he thought it was my
jacket oh that's right why did this you
know why because we went we were out
shopping in London and he bought this
rubber trench coat right and I kept
going you know I did I go if anybody
ever pees on you you'll be you'll be
safe and it was like a big you know joke
we were drinking and he didn't mind no
he thought it was funny